زياره مفاجئه لوزير الدفاع الروسي السرغي
شويغو الى المنطقه الى دانيتسكو تفقده
لمسار المعارك والعمليه العسكريه الخاصه
التي اطلقتها روسيا منذ عام تقريبا بالفعل
هذه الزياره لها
تفسيرين او شقين من يعني الرؤيه للخبراء
والمحللين منهم من يقول بانها تاتي في
اطار التنافس بين وزير الدفاع وما بين
مؤسس قوات فاغنر افغينيا الذي يطلق
تصريحات ناريه دائما حول جلوس القاده في
مكاتبهم بعيدين او بعيدين كل البعد عن ارض
المعارك وما يحصل في العمليه العسكريه
والشق الاخر هو تقدم القوات الروسيه في
عده محاور وتقديم الاوسمه كما راينا في
مشاهد الفيديو
للمقاتلين الشجعان كما وصفهم بالفعل هناك
صراع وتنافس ما بين القاده الروس على يعني
التقدم وتقديم الانجازات للكرملين هذا من
جانب الجانب الاخر هو محور مدينه باخمت
يعني بالامس بريجوجين قائد فاغنر اعطى
للرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي يومين مهله
للانسحاب وقال بان هذا الطريق هو الوحيد
المفتوح هو طريق شاسوفيار في الناحيه
الغربيه وشاهدنا بالامس توقف للعمليات
العسكريه من المحور الشمالي باتجاه المحور
الغربي الذي كانت قوات فاجنر تتقدم بلده
والبلده وصلت الى بلده
خرومافا
ثم توقفت مع المهله التي اعطاها قائد
فاغنر للقوات الاوكرانيه للانسحاب ربما 24
ساعه اخرى وتنتهي هذه المهله وتشهد
المنطقه عمليات عسكريه اخرى بهدف انقطع
هذا الطريق طبعا هناك مصادر عسكريه من ارض
المعركه تؤكد بان الطريق بكل الاحوال تحت
النيران المدفعيه الروسيه ولا تصل اي
امدادات عسكريه اوكرانيه الى الوسط ايضا
يعني التفاصيل بخصوص المعركه ما زالت قوات
فاجنر تطوق بلده باخمت من جميع النواحي ما
عدا الغربيه ودخلت في العمق تقريبا عده
كيلومترات من هذه النواحي الثلاث ووصلت
الى قلب المدينه لكنها لم تسيطر على الحي
الكائن في وسط المدينه